[Music]
matthew's in new york city hey matthew
how are you
i'm great dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm in a little bit of a car
situation um currently i'm on step two
no me my wife are on step two um i have
thirteen thousand dollars left in credit
card debt to pay off
um currently we just have one car i got
fleece three years ago pre dave ramsey
um
so that is up in february i'm five i'm
over the mileage and i'm gonna end up
owing five grand on it um i just
also on top of that i'm going to need to
buy a second car we just had a baby and
we currently only have the one car so
we're going to need that i'm going to
need to buy another car
and you're going to turn that one in in
february right
i have to turn that one into february so
we got about two cars
i had to buy two cars yes sir okay so
what do you make
uh
household income is around 220 000.
that's good news
okay
well i i think what we have is we have
a light at the end of the tunnel and
it's a train
coming at us
it's february
between now and february we got to buy
three cars
our two cars and we got a pa and we got
a five grand
and we got up somewhere and then after
some time after that we're going to pay
off 13 000 credit card debt but your
prior what's your first priority your
first priority is be able to turn this
car in so you need five grand treat that
like it's a debt
that's debt number one in your debt
snowball
uh priority number two is you currently
have one car we need to at least replace
the current one car
and so another five grand
for a five thousand dollar car
is number two and number three
i guess we can get the second car before
we pay off the credit card debt what do
you think
yeah that'd be great okay so that's
another five grand
so i need 15 grand to do the car flip
and i need 13 grand to pay off the
student loan or to pay off the uh
credit cards i'll get it spit out here
in a minute so you need 28 000 and you
make 200 between now and february if you
do all of that by february you're debt
free and have two paid for cars that are
worth 5 000 bucks each does that make
sense
yeah it makes perfect sense yeah i think
you can do all that you make a god you
make a god-awful amount of money it's
awesome i'm proud of you
but you're gonna you're not gonna do
nothing else don't talk to me about
going out to eat or going on vacation
you have a car crisis
and you're still have credit card debt
and you make a quarter million dollars a
year which is just straight up stupid so
you've got to clean this up right
okay does that make sense
yeah it makes sense yeah so uh just to
so fi so i can find a car for so
basically find two used cars for five
grand yeah yeah what do you do for a
living man
uh i work for the sanitation department
in new york city so i would need i need
a car with all-wheel drive because when
it snows that's my main job is to plow
the streets so
we i need to get i need to be able to
get to work get to work
so is there going to be any sort of let
me just say it this way you're going to
have to get over any sort of ego you got
about the salary you have and rolling
into work with a five thousand dollar
car because your co-workers are gonna
give you grief appropriately so and
you're gonna have to just smile and say
i don't know nobody nothing right
yeah you're gonna have to go and by the
way i don't want you to drive a 5 000
car the rest of your life i'm just
trying to get you past february
after february you have zero debt right
yeah that's your debt and you make 200
000 plus a year right
yes and so once your emergency fund is
saved up i would save up and move up in
car okay with cash
yeah
and uh so
i'm asking you to drive a 5 000 car for
less than a year
okay but if you'll drive like no one
else later you can drive like no one
else
that makes sense yeah i drove hoopties
after i went broke and people made fun
of me i had one the vinyl roof was torn
loose across the top when you drove it
it filled up there and looked like a
parachute going down the interstate and
uh i was so embarrassed
i was so embarrassed
it was so i would you know can you get
to work every day with worse is pulling
up in a church oh man and my face is red
the whole time and you know what i just
said screw it i don't care whether you
can take your hand and you just try to i
try to paste it on and then just slowly
poof back down that's it
no that's the headliner i'm talking
about the vinyl roof on top oh on the
outside like a tour
filled up there mine fell down on the
inside no this was this was the opposite
of aerodynamic yeah